Doni here with EGS news updates peter
molyneux creator of the fable Series
said that he thinks that the kinect is
an unnecessary add-on Molyneux in an
interview with edge said I actually wish
Kinect wasn't a requirement it feels
like an unnecessary out on to me maybe
it's because we're in England and it
doesn't really use the TV stuff but it
feels more and more like a joke
Molyneux also said that connect itself
could be finicky he said my son and I
sit there saying random things at it and
it doesn't work Microsoft could cost
reduce it by removing Kinect I'm sure
they're going to release an Xbox one
without Kinect it would be unthinkable
that they wouldn't ma Lanier appears to
have changed his opinion on connect his
former company Lionhead Studios was
creating a Kinect enabled game known as
project Milo that was officially
cancelled he also spoke optimistically
about Kinect functionality for favor the
journey the edge article also spoke to
Phil Spencer head of Xbox who said
Microsoft is always looking for feedback
from consumers but dropping the Kinect
requirement for Xbox one is not the
number one request for people instead he
says it's where are the great games so
what's important to you great games are
losing the Kinect
let us know in the comments and stay
tuned to gangster comm for more news
updates on the Xbox one